you're Flula yeah the vadym fight was so
crazy because I almost think you
benefited from it being in Brazil
because it seemed like Werdum was so
emotional and so ramped up because it
was in Brazil he's like chasing after
you which I was like this is crazy
yeah I think a little bit to that you
know we knew exactly everything you
wanted to do and I just wasn't falling
for anything you wanted right I'm for a
flying knee you want for a takedown you
want for a body kick I just wasn't
giving anything you wanted you know I
think you realized that I wasn't going
anywhere you also caught him before that
big punch - yeah when we watched the
fight we did a fight companion we
watched a fight you clipped him early
and I was like he's hurt you know you
could tell there was something going on
like when he got hit like and then he
tried to get it back and you know when a
guy gets hit and then just tries extra
hard to get it back like a lot of times
they're exposed and you just caught that
right hand perfect yeah what was that
feeling like man extra one but and then
you know I stopped fighting I looked
honest my coach was like oh hell yeah
you know like no hearts before but
before I said I'm a world champ I looked
at my coaches like we did it we did it
you know right so I told him we all did
it
you know that's some world champ and
that kind of like frightened tanka I was
blacked out - Ramona that's right but
you know it was it was it was awkward -
because it was so quiet in there now
here was myself screaming I was amazing
you know it was amazing we were clapping
when when you were you when you hopped
over the the Octagon and you're standing
there you're like I'm the world champ
I'm the world champ you like it was like
setting in like you can see it those
moments man those are some of my
all-time favorite moments when a guy
realizes like the biggest dream the
biggest accomplishment of his career
thus far at least in the seed a guy like
you win the title it's just there's
nothing like that man
there's nothing like that yeah
is great you know you know it's 45,000
we had about 15 people there so 45,000
people rooting for a breezy over there
she was 40 4905 15 there for myself and
then BOOM yeah it was my Mike's my
brothers and my cousins and now they're
all top row with my buddies and they
still want to knock them out they all
going yeah they're going crazy and
actually like yeah like we're sorry
they're like it's okay you know
congratulations they were really nice
about you
oh that's cool once have been silent in
there though when he dropped him oh it
was so awkward like it was so awkward
like huge us because I remember share
myself screaming like Mike what was the
crowd doing nothing there's quiet quiet
it was like like I'm my wife screaming I
hear I heard her screaming and that was
about it
Wow it was and you know clean was like
told 180 you know that was crazy too
I'm sure you know putting my ass and
then getting up when the zombie mode
didn't care after that Wow it's a crazy
time for you you know you're the UFC
heavyweight champion in the world I mean
one day you're gonna look back and we
talked any grandkids you're talking
about the time but now and you're the
[ __ ] champ of the world
yeah that's pretty intense yeah I'm
excited man just had some you know that
uh you know be proud of my wife my wife
my mom you know he's like yeah you did
some life yeah well what I'm excited
about to for the for you for this in
Ghana fight is there's gonna be a lot of
people buying this on pay-per-view
there's gonna be a big fight mm-hm
you know and these big fights this is
what makes you know a champion popular I
mean this is really this is I mean the
historically in boxing the voice said
that the health of the heavyweight
division it just represents like boxing
overall I don't think that's the case
anymore
because now in box you got all these
lightweight guys like Gennady golovkin
Canelo Alvarez
lomachenko all these big stars now that
are emerging in the lighter weight
divisions just because they're so
skillful and talented Andre Ward but I
think in the heavyweight division of the
UFC it's been a while
since people like really pumped up about
a big heavyweight title fight yeah yeah
I'm excited man you listen he's a good
tough dude you know I mean you bring the
pain
so why but I fortunately I'm not walking
out without that bow I'm still champion
still when you see a guy like that what
preparations like what what do you think
is different about him than guys you
fought before what are you gonna do
different well I mean I mean every guy
is different I mean every fight is
different you know I yeah oh my god it's
punching power I mean listen there's a
lot of guys at heart
I mean yeah there's there's no question
he does hit hard I mean but I'm gonna
like read stupid put myself in a
position when we get hit you know I'm
gonna do things that make him feel
uncomfortable and I'm gonna do what I'm
gonna do I'm not gonna sit there and let
him dude you want so I'm gonna dictate
what I want when you see the rest of the
heavyweight division do you see any
standouts or any guys that are coming up
that are exciting to you you don't
really that's that's a fascinating thing
cuz some people you know I talked to
Matt Hughes after Matt Hughes got beat
by BJ Penn and this is what he said it
was really fascinating because he had
he's got so much courage that guy like
to say to say this in an interview as
well he's like honestly it's a relief
he's like being the champ was like so
much pressure it was just it's
overwhelming so having this happen
honestly right now I feel relieved and I
was like wow that's crazy
yeah it's not like you gave up meaning
fought his heart out but he got caught
and got choked out and then to go from
that to say you know honestly is really
then rebounds and then gets back on the
horse and you know probably had to have
that experience just to have the
perspective that I don't know if you
ever had a perspective that you have but
your perspective is different in that
you like you don't seem to be concerned
well I mean I'm concerned there's no
question I think every fight you can you
know I'm nervous and always you know
never always gonna happen that's what
you know as real as a guest you never
know what's right but you're not
concerned at all these guys nipping at
your heels all those guys coming up the
ladder it's part of the game that's
where I signed up for yeah yeah I mean
we didn't like I said I want to do it I
wouldn't do it you know I knew that you
know one day I'll be the champ I knew
there are people coming for my belt
yeah I understand that and you know
there's a lot of good guys out there
that I mean you know like you know find
JD is fighting over doom you know no god
I mean they mean they all want a piece
of it and I understand that you no
matter who it is it's that he just meets
anyone came with fighting you know what
yeah you know I just / do me all I ever
wanted a piece of the tail